la réponse de Thomas dessus peut-être à
ce que vient de vous dire Marc-Philippe
de Brest sur votre présence à Sainte
solide mais au-delà aussi et bien sur ce
que digérald Darmanin qui on l'a dit a
souvent mis en accusation l'ultra gauche
ce matin moi j'assume ma présence je
l'ai dit la semaine dernière
voilà aux questions gouvernement la
semaine dernière moi j'assume ma
présence là-bas et personne ni mise de
l'intérieur ni mon collègue dobresses
pourra m'interdire de mettre les pieds
ma contravention il y a pas de problème
à la loi tout à fait bon j'assume de
désobéir de désobéir oui j'assume
j'assume de désobéir quand le le sujet
me semble légitime et surtout on a eu un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui la veille de
la manifestation nous promet la guerre
il nous promet des scènes de violence
nous promet des images de violence même
c'est même pas la violence en lui-même
qui l'intéresse c'est les images de
violence parce que c'est ses propos la
veille de de la manifestation et moi je
suis inquiet je suis inquiet quand le
ministre lui-même nous dit ça va être
très violent donc je vais voir ce qui se
passe sur le terrain et heureusement
aujourd'hui je suis allé voir provoquer
les violences
c'est votre propre initiative
individuelle bien sûr mais je fais ce
que je veux de mon mandat mais vous êtes
la nation oui très bien des choses très
bien vous pouvez faire mais je vais voir
sur le terrain ça me permet aujourd'hui
ça me permet aujourd'hui de dénoncer les
mensonges qu'on entend encore été répété
ce matin par le Ministre parce que
j'étais sur place donc moi j'ai vu j'ai
vu j'étais à côté d'une blessé j'ai vu
j'ai on a essayé d'appeler les secours
qu'on met du temps à venir donc ça je
l'ai vu il pourra dire ce qu'il veut il
pourra contester la Ligue des droits de
l'homme s'il veut qui a produit un
enregistrement qui est très clair sur la
question il pourra toujours essayer
dissoudre qui veut ce matin il peut le
marquer en gros sur sa présentation
comme il l'a fait ce matin moi j'étais
sur place je l'ai vu je l'ai vécu quand
vous êtes à côté d'une personne une
jeune femme qui a reçu un projectile au
visage dont les infirmiers nous disent
il y a un enfoncement orbital je sais
pas si vous vous rendez compte de ce que
c'est je sais pas d'où venait le
projectile je veux pas le savoir là on
était sur une zone qui était plutôt
apaisée on pouvait avoir des secours ils
ne sont pas venus il peut nous dire ce
qu'il veut ils sont venus ils ont mis du
temps à venir mais voilà
projectile que les manifestants lancés
sur les gendarmes vous étiez avec moi
sur place écoutez j'ai vu les images
voilà vous avez vu les images c'est ça
la différence pour vous et moi vous vous
aviez raison mais nous j'avais des
journalistes avec vous aussi interdire
le journal manifestation les gendarmes
n'ont pas l'utilisation des drones alors
que les manifestants les utilisent les
manifestations c'était des journalistes
qui avaient les drones je les connais
donc je sais qu'il y avait deux drones
en circulation je sais qui les qui les
utilisaient c'était pas les manifestants
c'est aussi un mensonge de Gérald
Darmanin ce matin vous pouvez toujours
écouter ce que dit le ministre moi
j'étais sur place donc vous pouvez dire
ce que vous voulez quelques heures de
vol très bien merci
Gérald Darmanin et pas mon témoignage
deux fois face à l'extrême droite
[Musique]